of all the mutations that lead to human
life the most important is also one of
the earliest the jump from simple
single-celled life to complex
multicellular life
it's hard to imagine them without
multicellularity intelligence as
possible you've got to have a big enough
organism so that specialization is
enough that some of the cells some of
the fraction of that organism can just
focus on being a brain the jump from
simple life to complex life begins
around 2.4 billion years ago what was
the trigger for this revolutionary
change scientists have boiled it down to
a single game-changing mutation
photosynthesis what happened was a
mistake a mutation led to a true
superpower the first bug to develop this
superpower is called cyanobacteria it
turns green and is now able to use
sunlight to create its own food supply
for the first time like heads own
internal energy source wherever you are
as long as you have sunlight you have
food so you could cut the umbilical cord
and break free and start to really
branch out into the environments of the
earth
the cyanobacteria thrive but the waste
product of photosynthesis is oxygen a
gas that is highly toxic to almost all
other primal life a weapon of mass
destruction at that point there wasn't
any free oxygen in the atmosphere this
was the first time this happened and as
these things evolved and flourished
they started dumping this basic poison
into the atmosphere most of life on
Earth is killed off by oxygen but the
creatures that survive evolved to use
oxygen and turbocharged their evolution
oxygen is so dangerous because it's so
reactive but that makes it a very good
fuel so the tiny percentage of life that
wasn't killed by the poisonous gas
oxygen all of a sudden could speed up it
had a more efficient fuel to use and
more energy means more complex molecules
more complex chemistry more complex
biology and that meant that these
creatures could evolve more rapidly
boosted by oxygen some single cells
evolved to do something that never done
before they team up single-celled
microorganisms really were smart when
they knew to cluster together because it
allowed them to have protection and work
kind of as a community
different cells within these communities
start to specialize in different tasks
eventually the communities start to
function as a single organism the stage
is set for the next superpower
multicellular life but a second global
catastrophe is coming in the background
cyanobacteria populations are still
exploding as they release the oxygen as
they grew it would have changed that the
chemistry of the entire planet as oxygen
fills the air it reacts with the early
atmosphere removing greenhouse gases
such as methane the result a rapid
cooling of the Earth's climate and this
we think would have tipped the climate
of the entire planet to row rate cold
collation it was what we call the
snowball earth and it was probably the
first climate catastrophe that happened
after life originated on earth snowball
earth lasts for 200 million years
eventually volcanoes release enough
greenhouse gases for the climate to
recover and the organisms that survive
inherit a warm oxygenated world perfect
for multicellular life multicellularity
really boobs and it seems to coincide
with a rise in oxygen over the next five
hundred million years oxygen levels
continue to rise and life uses it to
grow bigger and more complex
most of the major animal groups we see
today evolve fish turn into reptiles
reptiles turn into small mammals and
then primates
finally just two hundred thousand years
ago the first humans walked the earth